そこでこのヴィパッサナー瞑想というか
その四念処経の瞑想をすると
もう最後に出てくるのはこの法の観察でしょ
それで法の観察の場合
法って何なのかというと
いろんなことを法と言うんだけど
瞑想する人々がそういうなんだかんだも観察したって
もうね これはやりきれない
ですから こちらで選んでいるものを観察してみる
最初にこの五蓋を観察してみる
で 五蓋っていうのはどうしてももう経験あるもんですからね
瞑想し始めたら まあどうしても欲が出てくる
まあ派手な欲でなくたっても
自分の体可愛いぐらいでも欲でも出てくるんですね
もう早く寝たいとかね
もっともっとご飯食べたいとかね
で 何かそうやって音楽でも聞きたいとかね
そうやって瞑想中 いろんな欲が出てくるんですね
だから自分の体が可愛いという風な感じで出ているものも欲であって
ですから 激しい欲だけではないんですね
とにかく体が可愛いと思う限りは
瞑想はもうその蓋かけられちゃって
心が蓋かけられちゃって
この瞑想の方は進めないんですね
まあそうやってこの睡眠
昏眠睡眠が出てきたりするし
もう頭が混乱してしまって
妄想ばっかしで もう何がなんだかわからなくなったりもするし
まあそういう経験があるんだから
そういうのは五蓋なんですね
だからそこでこれはこういうこういうもの
これは欲である これは怒りである
これは情動である これは昏沈睡眠であるとかね
これは疑であるとかね
そうやって観察すれば
それは法の観察になるんですね
で 次に んーと のところは
テキストによって少々違うかもしれませんだけど
プナ
チェパランビッカレビッコダンメスダンマヌパッシーリヘラティパンチェスーパーダナッカンデースーカタンチェパナビッカレビッコダンメスダンマヌパッシーリヘラティパンチェスーパーダナッカンデースー
イ
ダビッカレビッコイティルーパンイティルーパッスサムダヨイティルーパッスアッタンガモイティヴェーダナイティヴェーダナヤサムダヨイティヴェーダナヤアッタンガモイティサンニャー
イティサンニャーヤサムダヨイティサンニャーヤアッタンガモイティサンカーラー
イティサンカーラー イティサンカーラーナンサムダヨイティサンカーラーナンアッタンガモイティヴィンニャーナンイティヴィンニャーナッスアッタンガモイティ
なんでサムダヤないんですか
え？ イティヴィンニャーナッスサムダヨないんだ
やっぱり サンダラがざっくりしてるんだよね
イティヴィンニャーナンイティヴィンニャーナッスサムダヨイティヴィンニャーナッスアッタンガム
アッタンガム サムダヨという言葉落ちています
ヴィンニャーナッスサムダヨ
で  まあ五蓋とかね そういうことを観察して
まあいくらかまあ落ち着いてきたら
まあ次にこの五蘊というものは何なのかと見ることはできるんですね
で 五蘊というのは色受想行識という四つなんですね
で そこ観察できる まあ色っていうのは体でありますからね
で 体のことはまあこの体はこれはまあ色であると
ルーパであると 色蘊であると
なぜ蘊かというと この体っていうのを個体ではなくて
いろんなものを組み合わせてできているものなんですね
仏教的に言えば地水火風というものが組み合わせたところで
体っていうものはできているんですからね
だからまあ そういうわけでルーパカンダと見るんですね
五蘊で見るんですね 私の体ですよと見るわけじゃないんです
もうルーパというあの集まりですよと
で その集まり このルーパも集まりで見ると体が変化していることはよくわかるんですね
で 瞑想を始めたら まあ始めた時から終わるまで体は全く同じじゃないんですね
ずっといろんな変化を起こしちゃうんですね
で 自分ではそれを明確にわかるはずなんですよ
どんどん鋭くなると やっぱり 1 分ごとに 30 秒ごとに
あるいは 1 秒ごとに変化していくんだと
この体は そこでそういう風に発見してほしい
これは体だ これは体だと観察したっても
それは瞑想にはなりません
体ではなくて ルーパとして見るんですね
色として見るんですね
色と言えば物質的なエネルギーであって
その物質的なエネルギーというものはずっと変化していく
1 分以内でもものすごいたくさん変化してしまう
だから 前の体と今の体が違う
今の体と次の体が違うと
この物質のエネルギーとして見ることは
ルーパカンダとして観察することなんですね
だからそれもいきなりできるわけじゃないんです
瞑想の経験ない人にとっては
体というのは個体であって
我が身であって 大事なもので見えるんです
変化しているようなのはまるっきり見えません
でも 鋭く鋭く集中力が出てくると
やっぱり変化していくんだと
これはもう一つの体ではなくて
物質の塊システムであって
組み立てているものであって
この物質エネルギーはずっと変化していくんだということが見えてきます
ですから ルーパとルーパがどのように生まれるかということと
どのように変わっていくかということを見ればいいんです
だから体で見る場合は
このこの集中するところは強調するところ
あの普通とは違うんですね
やっぱりこの体とエネルギーが生まれてくる
で現れ 消えていく そこら辺に集中して観察するんです
イティヴェーダナ イティヴェーダナ
あ これはジュであると
いわゆる感覚であると
まあいろんな感覚だから
体全体で感覚というものは流れているんだから
体に感覚がなければ体があるということもわからないし
ですから体は物体物質であるんだけど
その物質の中に感覚というエネルギーが働いているんですね
だからそれは心の これは感覚であると
足は足で感じることを
手は手で感じることを
頭は頭で感じることはもう感覚なんですね
そこで感覚も日参する
で 空で空として感じるし
楽として感じるし 風空風楽としてもその感覚を感じる
だから感覚自体も体中つなげているエネルギーだから
それも一つのウーパールーパー感で
十うんとして見るんですね
そこもつなげてるんですよ
例えば膝のところで痛みがあったり
腰のところでただ硬いとか感じたりするだけで
そうやって全ての感覚っていうのはつなげてずっと変化しているんですね
電気が流れているような感じで
体中ずっとこの感覚っていうのは流れている
体だけではなくて 体の感覚でも心の中にも感覚が生まれるんですね
心の中でも苦しみ 悲しみなど生まれるんだから
それも感覚で取るんです
それで感覚にしたっても
いろんな体中あるこの体にあるこの十が生まれて消えて生まれて消えて生まれて消えていく
例えば 膝の痛みは決してそのまま血液のようにそのまま流れて肩の方に来たんだって来るんだということがないんです
膝の感覚はそこで生まれて
そこで消える 肩の感覚はそこで生まれて
そこで消える そうやって
その場でその場で生まれる感覚をそこら辺でそこら辺で消えてしまっちゃいますね
だからといって もう感覚は外と繋げてるわけでもなくて
また自分たちでも一つの感覚体として繋げてはいるんだけど
流れていくわけじゃないんです
その場でその場で消えて消えて消えて消えていくんです
そこをそのように観察するんですね
次にあるのはサンニャーですね
サンニャーっていうのは
自分でも明確にわかるのも
物体のことをわかる体があるんだっていうこともわかるんで
わかりやすいんですね
それから それだけじゃなくて
ものすごいもう一つ働きあります
この妄想の働き 概念の展開点
あれ巨大な働きなんですよ
だからその概念の働き
これはサンニャーであると
だから人間の妄想の流れっていうのは
これも切れることなくずっと流れていくんですね
で 妄想がないんだと言ったっても
そこで確認したり 言葉でラベリングしたりするんだから
それも概念でしょうし
だからサンニャーは途切れることはないんです
関係ないものは妄想することはたまたまなくなりますけど
ちゃんと膨らみ縮み なんとか何とかできるかもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそれもサンニャーなんですね
妄想で言えばそれ自体も妄想なんですね
ですから妄想っていうのは便利な言葉で使っているだけで
専門用語じゃないんです
ですからもうサンニャーなんですね
そういうことで じゃあ人間にそのサンニャーがない瞬間があるかというと
それはないんです ずっと
サンニャーっていうのはもう回転して回転して終わりなく回転していく
それでサンニャーも好き勝手いろんなサンニャーでしょうに
ある一つのサンニャーだけ流れてるわけじゃなくて
まあバラバラでいろんなサンニャーが生まれては消えてく
生まれては消えていく
止まることないんですね
ずっと生まれて消えていく
生まれて消えていくということで
例えば膨らみ縮みだけ見ていたっても
膨らみというサンニャーと縮みというサンニャーが違うでしょうね
言葉では膨らみ縮みしかやってないんだけど
感覚鋭い人が膨らみの中でも膨らんでいるというその過程の中でずっとサンニャーが生まれていくでしょうし
そこでそこで膨らみを止まったところで縮んでいく
その過程でずっとサンニャーがもうずっと流れて流れていくということはわかるでしょう
だからそうやっても もう限りなくサンニャーっていうものは流れていくんだっていうことで見ると
このサンニャーの生まれとこのこれはサンニャーである
このようにサンニャーが生まれる
このようにサンニャーが消えるということはわかってきます
こちらではこの言葉でわかりやすく言ってるんであって
ただサンニャーっていうのは限りなく流れていることだけ見ていれば
それはもう見たことになるんです
で サンカーラっていうのはやっぱりこの欲
意欲みたいなもんなんですね
欲ではなくて意欲 いわゆるこのずっと我々の心の中で何かしたい
やりたいという そのエネルギーが働いてるんですよ
それも瞬間瞬間生まれてくる
その 何かしたい やりたいんだから何かしてやったりするんですね
だから人間にできることっていうのは
考えることと喋ることと体を動かすことなんですね
それしかできないんです
だからマノーサンカーラ
ワチーサンカーラ カーヤサンカーラしか
その３つしかないんです
意欲っていうのは結局は３種類しかない
で そこを分析していない人にとっては
やっぱり人間にはいろんなもう意欲があるんだとかね
もう言ってはいるんだけど
仏教から見れば 分析してみればとても簡単にわかるもんなんですね
例えば天に生まれ変わりたいとかね
偉い人間になりたいとか
まあいろんな意欲が出てくるでしょうね
そこだけ見て 自分の考え方
生きる目的はこういうものだとか
そういうのは単なるもうマノーサンカーラしかなんもないんです
頭で何か考えてるだけのことで
それで体でもカーヤサンカーラが生まれてくる
例えば右足を運んで下ろしたところで左足を上げたくなるんです
上げて運びたくなる それはカーヤサンカーラなんです
それから喋りたくなる
それはワチーサンカーラなんですね
ですから その意欲というもの
何かやりたい 何かやりたいということも決して消えることはないんですね
それもすっと流れていくんですね
次から次へとこのやりたがっているエネルギーが変わっていくんですね
例えば 喋りたいエネルギーと歩きたいエネルギーっていうのは随分違うでしょうね
ご飯食べたいエネルギーとご飯食べることと随分違うでしょうね
ご飯食べる時でもじっとこのサンカーラが変化していくんですね
もう手を伸ばしたい 箸を取りたい
これ入れ 運びたい 噛みたいとかね
それで食べる その間に他のことをやりたくまたなっちゃうんですね
その時に誰かと喋りたくなったりする
とにかくこのやりたいという気持ちには終わりがないんですね
それで生きてるんですよ
生きてるっていうことは
こうやってこの３種類のサンカーラの流れなんですね
だからサンカーラの通りに行動するんです
だからこの微妙にわかりにくいんですよ
例えば妄想自体はサンカーラですか？と言えば
妄想はそうなんですね
サンニャーなんです でもサンカーラがなければサンニャーしないんですよ
呼吸も同じで 呼吸もやりたいんだからやってるんですから
そこら辺で分かりやすいんです
吸いたいという気持ちが出て吸う
それで吐きたいという気持ちが出てきて吐くんですよ
これを厳密に 見られるんです
だからこの歩く瞑想をよくやってくださいというのは
まあ歩く瞑想をよくやると
この運びたがる気持ちでは見えてくるんです
自動的に 止まりたいとね
止まりたがる気持ち 回りたがる気持ち
また足を運びたがる気持ちとかね
わかってくるはずなんです
そこでそうやってちらちらとサンカーラを確認できるんです
だからサンカーラと行動というのはほぼ同時に起こるようなもんなんですね
そこでサンニャーと厳密につなげているんです
これよく気持ちだから
それはですから 頭の概念と厳密につなげているんです
離れません 離れない 一緒なんですけど
行動としては別に確認できる行動なんですね
だから人間で何なのかというと
このずっと変化して流れている体がある
体という物質的なエネルギーがある
その物質のエネルギーのシステムを感じる感覚の流れがある
痛みとして楽として感じる
楽しみとして感じる感覚の流れがある
例えば目があると光に反応する耳に耳が音に反応する
そういうものも感覚なんです
それを反応しなきゃもう機能しないことになりますから
死んだことになるんですね
鼻があるともう香りに反応する
体が寒さに硬さに反応すると
ですから そういうものに反応する働きが終わりなく変化して流れていく
そこはサンニャーで それで反応しちゃうとサンカーラも生まれていく
それに付いてサンニャー生まれてくる
こういうものだ こういうものだと
同時に次に何が何をやるんですか？次に何をやるんですか？という
あの次にやることが出てくる
そうやってこのこの次に何やりますか？というような感じで生まれてくるエネルギーもエネルギーはサンカーラでありますね
だからこのない瞬間はないんです
体の中でサンカーラがない瞬間はない
サンニャーがない瞬間はありません
そういうのは生まれる
必ずしも生まれて消える
生まれて消える で  5番目はヴィンヤーナですね
識という知るということ
で それは簡単に知るということ
目で知る 耳で知る 体で知る
頭の中でも知るということです
これ概念と違う ただ知るという機能
認識という機能 概念と違う働きなんですけど
結局サンニャーとも厳密につなげていて
一緒に行動しているんですね
知ると同時にサンニャーが生まれちゃう
で サンニャーが生まれると同時にもうサンカーラも生まれちゃう
だったら何するんですか？と
次にしたがることが次の次に生まれる
音が耳に触れる 触れた瞬間でもう知るでしょうに
それはもうヴィンヤーナなんですね
で そこで概念が瞬時にもう生まれてるんですよ
サンカサンニャーが どんな音かと
次にそれに何す何しますかと
自分でやりたいことをそこに生まれてるんで
音に対して 次の瞬間でそれをやるんですよ
で それは音の瞬間でね
耳に音が触れたとた途端
もう反応して終わっちゃうんです
反応してもう何かあの変
何か行動を残して終わっちゃうんです
だからまあ恐ろしい速さで起こるんだけど
その識というものはずっとまた終わることなく起きているんですね
だから感覚と知るということは何なのかと
全く違うんです で 知ることは我々は感覚で知ってるんです
で 音が目に触れると感覚が生まれるんですよ
感覚が生まれたんだということは
もうもうとっくに音を知ってるんですね
音を知ってるということはヴィンヤーナで
そのようにこの心の流れではなくて
この知ることの流れ も見るんですね
だからヴィンヤーナももう各サンニャーによって変わる
で 各妄想によってヴィンヤーナも変わってしまっちゃうと
そうやってヴィンヤーナの流れがあるんだと
よし そこで言ってアッジャッタンワダンメスダンマヌパッシヴィヘリって
これ自分の体について色受想行識を見ろ
それからバヒッダーワダンメスダンマヌパッシヴィヘルって自分だけじゃなくて
他の外の世界を見ても
みんなにそれ５つしかないんだと
色受想行識以外何もないんだっていうことで
他人の色受想行識もまあ見てみる
で そうやって次にこの内と外を両方見てみる
いわゆるまとめて一般論として世の中にあるのは色の流れ
受の流れ 想の流れ 行の流れ
識の流れだよと それぐらいわかると
そちらに天もいないし
神もいないし もう犬も猫も誰も別にどうったことなくて
ただの色受想行識でしょうと
自分もいないんですよ
その色受想行識っていうのは大変大事な尊いもうものかと我ですかと
変化しない何かなんだけど
何もないんですね 結局流れ流れ流れだけであって
そこに自分もないし 他人もないし
我もないし 何もない 何だか流れだと
そこはわかれば そこはもう悟りの世界にもうそこで入っちゃうんです
だからそこら辺どこででも悟りに至る可能性はあります
次 また 人によって見方が変わるし
あの あの五蘊わかる人もなかなかわからない人もいます
だから五蘊わからない人にとっては
また次のことにチャレンジしてみればいいんですね
プナチャパランビッカウェビククダンメスダンマヌパッシヴィヘラティチェスアッジャッティカバヒレスアヤタネスカタンチャパナビッカウェビククダンメスダンマヌ
パッシヴィヘラティチェスアッジャッティカバヒレスアヤタネス
イ
ダビッカウェビククチャックンチャパジャナディルーペーチャパジャナティヤンチャタドゥバヤンパティッチアウッパジティサンヨージャナンタンチャパジャナティヤタ
ーチャアヌッパナッササンヨージャナッサウッパードーホーティタンチャパジャナティヤターチャウッパナッササンヨージャナッサパーナホーティタンチャパジャナテ
ィヤターチャパリーナッササンヨージャナッサアヤティンアヌッパードーホーティタンチャパジャナティ
というやり方で見ます
そこでこの十二処と言うんですね
あの十ニか所というところで場所であのサティを実践してみます
この十ニか所で言ったでも六処なんですけど
我々の体で六つのところであのヴィンヤーナが生まれるんです
ヴィンヤーナというこのエネルギーが六か所に生まれるんですね
だからヴィンヤーナだから前ではヴィンヤーナちょっとわからないんだと五蘊の世界ではと
いう人にとってはこの六か所で捕まって
見ればいいんです 六処っていうのは眼耳鼻舌身意ですね
目でヴィンニャーナが生まれるんです
色が目で だから目で知ってるでしょうね
外の世界あるんだと知ってるのは目で知ってるんだから
この知るということはヴィンニャーナなんですね
だからチャックと目で見るものにはまたルーパと言うんですね
前のところで体にルーパと言ったんだけど
それ物質の流れでという意味で言うんですね
目で見るものにはルーパと言うんですね
だから目で見られるものも結局は物質の流れなんですね
だから物質が流れてこなきゃ目で見ることができない
物質は変化していかないと目で見ることができないんですね
止まると見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから流れていかないと
そこで目があって こういう場合は決してこの科学的な分析は意味がないんです
科学的に見ると間違うんです
だから科学的なことは使わない
普通の科学的な世界でいうのは
目に光が入って中に入り込んじゃうんだと
それは経験できないんですね
我々には単なる まあものは見える
それで十分です 私たちにとってはそちらにタンスがあると見えるんですね
で どのように見えるかって
やっぱりこの形と色なんですね
色で見えるんです 色で区別するんです
高いか短いかということも色でするんですよ
こちらパーリ語はルーパなんですけど
日本語の場合は色という漢字書いてるんですね
おそらく パーリ語では五蘊のところにはもうルーパと言うんです
そこで目の対象にはルーパと言うんです
日本語訳では五蘊の対象は同じ色でしたっけ
同じように書いてあります
同じ漢字  はい を知る だから色を知る
物々の色を知る 色を知る
とにかく目に入るものは色で知ってるし
ですから それぐらいでいいんです
外に何か対象があって
あってでもなくてでもいいんだけど
それは目に触れて そこで知るんだと
で このように知るんですね
で ここにタンスがあって
で こちらに目があって
それで知るんだと でなきゃタンスがあるという認識は生まれませんね
そこで目のヴィンニャーナですから
チャックヴィンニャーナと言うんですね
だからタンスがあって
目があって 今タンスがあるんだというヴィンニャーナが生まれたんだと
それだけじゃない 次に心で何が起こるんですかね
見たところで煩悩が生まれるんですね
束縛が生まれるんですね
それを見るんです 観察するんです
その三セットなんです
で 音の場合はそちらに音があって
音があるんだからね ここで耳があるんだからと
そこで聞こえたということになっちゃったと
ソータヴィンニャーナが生まれたんだと
それ次にこういう煩悩が生まれたんだと
こういう束縛が生まれたんだと
サンヨジャナが生まれたんだと
だからそれでサンヨジャナという煩悩というか
束縛というか 感情というか
言葉そんなにもう厳しく考えなくてもいいんだけど
で ずっと生まれているんですね
だから外に音がある限り
この耳には聞こえる 聞こえる限りサンヨジャナが生まれていくんです
外に見えるものある限り
目が開けている限り見えてしまうんですよ
見える度に見える度に見える瞬間瞬間ごとにサンヨジャナが生まれていくんですね
だからこの終わりなく生まれていくと
我々は目と耳と鼻とたまたま鼻で香り嗅いだり嗅がなかったりもしますけどね
でも耳では結構音を聞いてるんでしょうに
目が開けてる時は絶やすことなくずっと見えているでしょうに
それで体でずっといろんなことを感じているでしょうに
だからもう全然終わることなく
ものすごく産業じゃなくという煩悩というか
束縛というか 感情というか
どちらでもいいらしいし
煩悩 束縛 感情というものがずっと生まれていくんですね
終わることなく もう生まれ
生まれて消えて生まれて消えていくんですね
だから六将だから六番目は心ですね
意志ですね 意志の中でいろんなアイディアが想がサンカーラが生まれていくんですね
概念が生まれる 生まれるたびに感情も生まれるんですね
妄想と一緒に必ずもう感情あるんですね
逆に感情がなければ妄想も生まれませんし
で 生まれた妄想に続いて
次にまた感情が生まれる
その感情でまた次の妄想が出ちゃう
その妄想でまた次の感情が生まれる
そうやってもう止まりません
だから一つのことを妄想としたら
次のこと妄想する だから関連あって妄想するわけじゃないんです
だから妄想見た人々は知ってるだろうと思いますけど
で 外の 例えば電車の音を聞こえたとする
瞬時にそれで妄想する
山手線だ 山手線だと だけど
全ての人間が山手線だと妄想するわけじゃないでしょ
なんでその差ですかね
あの音に添いて生まれた感情によって
その差が山手線だと思うか
もう電車だと思うか あるいは結構殺傷があるんだと思うか
同じ音なんですけど その同じ音に添いてすぐ次に出てくる妄想でどんな煩悩ができたかっていうこと
すぐ簡単にわかるんです
そこで妄想から次の妄想しちゃうでしょうね
山手線だと妄想した人が次に何妄想するかわかりますかね
それはもうなかなか言いにくいんだけどね
まあ次にその人に生まれた感情によって次のことを妄想する
まあ子供のぐらいだったら私にちょっと妄想して言えますけど
子供だったら山手線だと思ったところで
新幹線次の次に新幹線のことを妄想するかもしれません
子供っていうのは電車のこと好きだから
もっとかっこいいものを妄想してしまっちゃうとかね
他の人は次にすぐ家のことを妄想するかもしれません
こういう関連性なんですね
どういう関連で 電車だ
電車で家に行くんだという
電車だと言った途端 もう家に対する妄想が
感情が生まれた 欲の感情が生まれたんだから
家のことを思ったりするし
すぐに家のことを思ったところで
また欲ではなくて違う感情が生まれてるはずかも
かもしれません 家で喧嘩して帰ったとなれば
次にそのことに心が行ったりする
だから瞬時に電車の音
あいつはあの言ったことはとんでもないことではなく
次にすぐ妄想する可能性あります
だから見たらどんな関係ですかと
概念だけでは関係見えませんよ
だから人間の妄想っていうのは
そういう具体的な関連性がないんです
いい加減なことを妄想する
でも関連性あります 煩悩の世界でちゃんと関連性があります
ちゃんと煩悩の世界でつなげているんです
だから煩悩だけ見ると
あ 一本の流れだということ見えるんですね
だから輪廻転生を知りたい人々は
この概念で輪廻転生を見ようと思っても
それできません 私は過去でどんな人間に生まれていたんだと
その概念で見ることはできません
なぜならば 人の概念にはそうやって論理的な関連性がないんだから
電車の音だ 新幹線って面白いんだということと
電車の音だ 今家の旦那が本当にもうとんでもないやつだという関連性ないでしょ
その概念には でも感情から見ると関連性があります
例えば電車だ 山手線だ
面白いんだと で 次にもっと面白いんだと
それは新幹線であると
という風に子供の場合はなるかもしれません
で 他の人にとってはもう電車の音に続いて家だとかね
そこで生まれてくるのは
自分の囚われているところ
それで囚われてるところからまた怒りとかね
欲とか もう何か生まれるかわかりません
とにかくそうやってこの感情によって妄想が流れていく
それで我々には眼耳鼻舌身意という心が生まれる場所が 6つありまして
そこに色声香味触という 6つの対象が触れる
目には色 耳には音 鼻には香り
舌には味 体には熱と硬さ
それから頭に浮かぶものには法と呼ぶんですね
その 6つのものが触れて識が生まれる
識が生まれたら次に感情が生まれる
一般の人々はそれは知らないんです
瞑想でそこのその方向へラベリングしてほしい
ほしいんですね で 音と
で 気持ち悪いという感情が生まれた
それは怒りなんですね
気持ちいいと思ったら
そこは欲 で そうやって
まあそうでない場合はほとんど無知という知ですね
貪瞋痴の まあそういうどちらかのことが生まれてくる
で サンヨウジュナという場合はその 6つじゃないんですけどね
サンヨウジュナといえばこの10種類なんです
だから10種類まで行くのは難しいだろうと思いますけど
やっぱりなんとか束縛が生まれたんだと
束縛っていうのは好きということじゃなくて
嫌いということも束縛なんです
いわゆる関わりなんですよ
関わりが生まれたんだと
だからサンヨウジュナの一番いい訳は関わりということなんですね
例えば嫌いな音に束縛されて
まあそれはなんとなく意味がわからなくなっちゃうんですね
嫌いだから自分がそこから逃げたいだけのことなんですけど
で 逃げたらそれで問題解決するでしょ
逃げてないんです 離れれば問題解決する
でも我々は離れたい対象に対して離れません
関わりを作る だから怒りなんです
人のことを嫌になったら
その瞬時にそれを忘れちゃえばいいでしょうに
離れればいいでしょうに関係ないと
関係ないと思ったら心は安らぎになるんだけど
関係ないところじゃなくて
なんでそういうことをするんですかと
悪いんじゃないんですか？とかね
それで怒り作るんですね
怒り作ったということはもう束縛なんですね
煩悩なんですね ですから
関わりということ意味で理解すればいいんです
耳に音が触れる 関わりが生まれる
目に何か形が映る 関わりが生まれる
舌に味が入る 関わりが生まれる
頭に妄想が生まれる 関わりが生まれる
関わりが生まれるんだから
全然離れませんね そういうものから
まあそこで欲も怒りも生まれてくる
三業での別な 10種類があって
私がいるんだっていう概念は一番目の三業でね
サッカヤディティ それで因果法則はわからなくて
いきなり電車が音やで言った途端
もう因果法則がわかってないんですね
だから音 音と確認しなさいっていうことは
この因果法則をわかってもらうためなんです
カラスの音だからカラスの音やで確認すれば何が悪いんですかと
みんなもう威張って言うんだけど
それは間違ってるんです
自分が頭がいいんだから
瞬時にカラスの音だとわかったんだと
そのカラスを何種類かとわかったんだと
すごい高慢で言うんですね
瞬時にもう全部わかったんだから
そこはもう何が悪いんですかと
電車の音っていうよりも
このもう車輪のガタガタにする別々に
その音までわかってしまったと
ああ 鋭くて良かったなと
だからそうやって観察するの何が悪いんですかとかね
それ悪いんです とにかく
それはもう因果法則はわからない
永久的に だからそれ単なる知ったかぶりなんですよ
世の中の知ったかぶりと仏教の真理の世界は随分違いますから
この妄想概念に流れることは知識の世界で
それはもう何のこともないんですね
だから音で終わってもらって
音で終わってもらったら
音に対する心の中でどんな関わりが生まれるかっていうことを見てもらえば
因果法則は出てくるんです
そうすると煩悩がなくなるはずなんですね
だから大雑把で カラスの音や電車の音やというと
もうもう自分がいるんだというサンニャーもありまして
もう因果法則を知らないという
この打ち切っちゃサッカヤ
打ち切っちゃディですか
ディもそこに表れてるし
で まあ煩悩では 10種類とにかくありますけど
まあだいたいこのまあ
生きていきたいという欲とね
カーマッチャンで それから怒り
えっと それからまあいろんなえらいこと
やりたがることとかね
修行したがるや 戒律守りたがるわとか
かっこつけたくなるだけなんです
あんなもんは 一般の人の世界の中で自分が聖者だ
仙人だ もう半年間あるいは 1年間あるいはもうもう南アジアにある各道場を訪ねてきたんだとかね
もうそんなふうな もうこれは戒禁衆であって束縛煩悩なんです
そうやっていろんな道場巡りやってる人は
単なる道場破りだけで
自分の精神破って帰るだけで
一人も成功したケースはないんです
成功した人はそこでその道場で止まりますからね
まあとにかくそうやって世の中でそういうふうにカッコつけたがる煩悩がありまして
まあそれはまあ戒禁衆というふうな
まあ訳なんですけど それから生きていきたいという欲がありましてね
[背景音楽]生きていきたいという欲は
この必ず続けていっちゃうし
そこで生きることは嫌になってしまっちゃうんですね
それも一つの欲なんですね
カーマーラーガ ルーパラーガ
カーマーラーガっていうのはこの体に対する欲で
ルーパラーガっていうのは存在
生きていきたいという欲で
アルーパラーガっていうのは生きていきたくないという欲で
それから 10番目はヴィッニャーですね
無明なんですね まあまあ
とにかくそこへ 10種類に煩悩を分けることは
まあ一応不可能でしょうね
この場合ではね ですから
一応耳と音と何か心の中で感情が生まれたと
そうやって見てみれば
結構十分だと思います
それからこの生まれた感情から離れなくなっちゃって
それに次いで次の妄想まで作ってしまっちゃうでしょ
そこら辺見ればいいんです
そこでサンニャージャナが生まれるでしょ
サンニャージャナは知る
で ウッパンナッサ サンニャージャナッサ パハーナン ホーティ
ウッパンナッサ サンニャージャナッセ
生まれたサンニャージャナのパハーナン
消えること ホーティ あります
パンチャパジャーナ それも知る
だから あの 例えば静かに自分が瞑想して膨らみ縮みと見ている
その時も煩悩が生まれているんです
サンニャージャナが それでいきなり音が聞こえちゃうと
今あったサンニャージャナと違うサンニャージャナが瞬時に生まれちゃうんですね
だからもう瞬間にこの違うサンニャージャナが生まれてくる
違う関わりが生まれてくる
だから情報入る次第にこの関わりが変わっちゃうんですね
私はこちらの関わりだから放っておきなさいという気持ちにはならないんです
例えば音が面白くて音を聞いてるんだと
まあサンニャージャナが強ければ
ある音を聞いている サンニャージャナが
関わりが強い それ聞いてると他のことがあったらこれを後回しにしちゃいますけど
大体それはもうたまたまだけであって
関わりがもう例えば音に関わりがあって音を聞いてるんだけど
誰が体触っちゃったらすぐそこに関わりが入ってしまっちゃうんですね
何か見えたらそこでその関わりが変わってしまっちゃうんですね
それでサンニャージャナが生まれる
生まれたサンニャージャナが消える
消えたサンニャージャナはまた
消えたサンニャージャナはまた出てこないとというふうな感じで見ればいいんです
それで耳に対しても 鼻に対しても
舌に対しても 体に対しても
心に対しても その三つを見てみてほしいと
そのファンクション その機能
そのシステムを見ることは
ここでホーと言うんですね
だから十分見られますよ
だから五を見えるよりは簡単なんです
順番に見る必要ないんです
まず目からと 次に耳から
次鼻に行きます 次舌に行きますとかね
そう言った方が皆様がかっこよくて
もう大変大変人気があるだろうと
そういうもうもうかっこよくやる必要ないんです
まあそれその時その時に感じたことを見ればいいんです
耳に音が入っちゃったら
もう感情が生まれたら
そのシステムを見てみる
それで体で痛みが出てきて
それに次いで嫌味やらね
まあ嫌な気持ちやら何か生まれちゃったら
そこでそのシステムを見ればいいんですね
その間で もし何か妄想が入っちゃって
そこでまた感情が入り込んだ
まあどうせ入り込みますけど
まあ気になるのは強力な感情だからね
そこでそれを観察すればいいんだ
だからそうやって適当にその都度その都度見ればいいんです
これはまあ 1から 6まで順番でやらなくちゃいけないとか
6から 1まで逆順でやらなくちゃいけないってことではないんです
ただ 眼耳鼻舌身意に触れる色受想行明即法は
まあもうそれぞれ適当に見てみる
そのシステム見ると このヴィンニャーの別に見なくちゃ困るんだということでなくなっちゃうんですね
色受想行 体 何でしたっけ？ルーパというね
体を見なきゃいけない
それはないんですよ 目が見てるんだから
目を見てるんだから 耳を見てるんだから
それで色受を見たことになっちゃうんですね
ですから 色受想行識で難しい人が六処で
十二章でいいんです 十二章観察すればちゃんとあのセット五つ見たことになるんです
見方がちょっと違うだけで
認識中心に見るんだから
ヴィンヤーの中心に見るんだから
そこでサンカーラあまり見られないかもしれませんだけど
やっぱり感情見てるでしょ
感情の中にサンカーラが入ってるんですね
だから感情が 関わりが生まれたらどうせ次のことをやりたくなるでしょうに
それも関わりだから ですから
まあそれ見られているんです
そのように見れば それから自分の体も同じ機能で
他人の体も同じ機能だと
どんな体にでもその六つはついてるんです
その六つの中で だいたい目が入ってない体あるし
耳が入ってない体があるし
鼻の機能入ってない体あるんだけど
意識は入ってるんですね
体は入ってるでしょうに
だからこの十二種類のこの機能器官
それは十二じゃなくて六種類の機能器官
六つもついてる生命がいて
いくつか欠けてる生命もいます
それだけなんです 七つついてる生命はいません
だから全体的に一切の生命の認識世界はただそこのみ
特別な認識器官を持ってる人は一人もいません
で そういうことで 世の中ってのは
存在ってのはそういうものだと理解してみればいいんです
だから他人の体を見なくちゃならないんですね
例えば神の言葉を聞いて
私は神であるとかね あるいは私には神の言葉がちゃんと聞こえてるんだとかね
あるいは直接私は神 神が私とコンタクトを取ってるんだとかね
言って商売やってる人々いるでしょうに
で 宗教は商売なんでしょ
結局はもう他に何もないんです
商売か政治かどっちなんです
だからまあ昔は政治とも絡んでいたんだけど
今も絡んでるんだけど
ただ政治のために宗教というものを作ってるんです
例えば中東の国々っていうのはね
宗教は何のため ただの政治で人殺すためなんです
インドネシアでもね もうずいぶん人殺してるでしょうに
キリスト教の人々やら中国系のね
華僑の人々っていうのも一気に殺しちゃうんですね
だから迷惑だとかね 分裂するんだとかね
もう神を侮辱しているのは何か言い訳してて
人殺しちゃう もう神を守るために
ためには我々は何でもやるんだとか
イスラム人が威張ったりする
とにかく自分持ってる怒りをね
表現しているだけのことなんですね
誰一人神を見たことでもないし
キリスト教の人を見たことでもないし
イスラムの人を見たことでもないし
ただ誰かさんアホが書いた本を持ってきて
その本をそのまま読んだりして
本は本だからね そこは誰批判したってよろしいでしょうし
書いたもんだから 批判したったら殺される
世界中で誰でも批判したら殺す
キリスト教もずっと批判したら殺すってことをやってきたんだけど
最近できなくなっちゃってやらない
でもできればやる あんな本なんかはね
誰が書き換えたってもいいし
私のバージョンですよと
本だから ただの言葉だからね
ですから 例えばもう神の言葉とか何とか言ったっても
結局その人の意識でしょ？心でしょ？心に概念が浮かぶだけでしょ
我々にも心に概念 いろんなもの浮かぶでしょうね
もう変な妄想生まれるでしょうね
ありっこはしない妄想生まれるでしょうね
では 我々はありえない妄想が生まれたっても
くだらんことだと分かっているんだから
あまり病気にはなりません
あるいは ただ単に心体が軽くて空を飛んでいければいいなとかね
思う可能性はあるし 子供の頃はだいたいそういう妄想っていうのはもう結構するでしょうに
で 自分飼ってるペットはね
まあよく飛んでくれるんだったら
自分が乗ってあっちこっち行くでしょうとかね
そうやって妄想する場合もあるし
あるいは子供だったらね
まあ犬と夢で喋る 犬もいろんなことを喋るとかね
まあそういうのはもう単なる頭の中の妄想で
それでもってこの子はやっぱり自分の犬が喋るんだよとかね
言いふらしてはしません
そうすると病気だとみんな言ってますからね
でも私に神の言葉が聞こえるんだと言ったら
誰も病気だと言わないのは何なのかね
私は神と言ったらあんた病気ですよと病院行きなさいと
なんで言わないんですかね
それぐらい他の人も病気なんです
あれはただの病気なんです
変なことを考えて 空の上のことをもうもうもうこの世の中でないんですね
心は だから そういう風にいろんな呪文唱えたり
瞑想したりする人々を見てください
なんか変でしょ？みんな
現実的じゃないでしょ
だから病気なんですね
だから妄想するのは病気じゃないんです
それみんなやってますから
この妄想は実相だと思うと困るんです
例えば人のことをね 殺してやりたいと思うのは別に怒りだけであって
それほど問題じゃないんです
殺すことだけが問題なんですね
時々自分の子供に対しても
本当にもう産まなかった方がよかったんじゃないかと腹が立つという時もありますけど
本当はそれはまあただその時言っただけですよと
それだけでしょうね 全然真面目にそんな妄想はね
思うわけじゃないでしょうに
真面目に思ったなら 母親がね
その子を産まなかった方がよかったんだと思ったら大変なことになるでしょうに
だから妄想っていうのは誰でもするんだけど
その妄想自体 実相になっちゃうんですね
そこをみんなにある病気なんですよ
我々はかなりの量のことを妄想している途中で
何パーセントか本当やと思っちゃうんです
それで世の中でいっぱいトラブルが作っちゃうんです
100%思う人々は宗教を作るんです
大体 1割  2割ぐらい 本当やと思って
普通の人々はね 自分もそうする
世界の頭の中に浮かぶものの
1割  2割ぐらいは本当やと思っちゃいますから
その分はトラブル作っちゃうんです
苦しみも作っちゃうんですね
ただ妄想だけで見る人が全然トラブルは作りません
ですから この 6書だけでも観察しちゃうと
この疑が消えるんですよ
本当に神がいるかいないか
その疑あるでしょうね
人が死んじゃったら本当に生まれるかないかとかね
疑いが消えるんです そんなことはもう実証もできないし
実証できないものは信じるんだったら信仰で信じるだけでしょうと
だから勝手に信じればいいし
勝手に信じなければそれはそれでいいし
なぜ信じるか信じないかことをするんですかね
それ煩悩でしょ やっぱり輪廻する
死んだら生まれ変わるんだと私は信じています
煩悩なんです あれは 自分
我が身に対して 「私は信じませんよ」と
それは煩悩なんです 我が身に対して
下らんことを考えちゃうんですね
ですから そこをこの知識の認識機能のシステム見た人々が
煩悩の働き見た人々が
こんな下らんことを 世の中のあれだこれだとか考えて
そういうそこから心が綺麗になるんですね
だからもう疑の煩悩が消えるはずなんです
だからその時点になってくると
やっぱり預流果になるんですよ
実体があるんだっていうこと消えるでしょ
これは六入りのファンクションしかないんだから
六入里も限りなく消えて消えていくんだから
だからあまりにも激しく生まれるんだから
絶えず生まれるんだから
実体で見てしまっちゃうんだと
だから噴水があるんだと思うのはそういうわけでしょ
本当は噴水がないでしょ
絶えず水が流れてるんだから
噴水があると思ってしまうんだと
かわいそうやと しようがないと
そう思う人々のことも
自分もこの流れが見えていなかったんだから
今までやっぱり自分がいるんだと思っていたんだけど
結構これすごいもんだと
こんなに勢いで こんなに速さで
こんなに瞬滅的に生まれてくると
これはやっぱり自我があるんだとね
思うのは無理はない話だと
だから全ての生もそう思っているんだと
あ こんなこと本当はないんだということはわかるでしょうに
それは預流果なんですよ
体験で 経験でそれを発見したら
その人にはもう疑がなくなっちゃうし
だから預流果になって 「
あんた輪廻信じてますか？」とかね
聞いたっても 「信じてないんですか」とか
別にもう関係ない話ですよと
そうならば 聞く人が煩悩を持っていて 「
私が死んでから生まれるか」と知りたがっているだけなんですね
調べると 私はもうすごいもう意地悪質問をするんだからね 「
あんたどう思いますか？」と 「
あんた死んだら生まれ変わりたいんですか？」とかね
逆にごだけ 説明していてもまるっきり答え出てこないし
わからないしね そういう人々が
だから輪廻転生っていうのは
こういう風にある個体が飛んでいって
他のところに行く こちらも個体がないんだから
これはもう説明できるわけじゃないんです
今も輪廻転生しているでしょうに
瞬間しか現象がないでしょうに
生まれた現象は違う現象で置き換えるだけでしょう
だから現象の置き換えだけなんです
それには終わりがないんです
どう見たっても その科学的な真理をみんなもう輪廻転生とかね
あるいはまあレインカーネーションとかね
生まれ変わりとか いろんな言葉で言っても
そこであるのは我論なんですね
それは 我論ついてるんだから
そこは間違いであって
我論ついてないんだったら仏教的な変化の流れ
だから流れっていうのは言葉であって変化なんですね
変化だけ見てみれば それでもう輪廻の問題解決するんです
変化してるんだと だから
ある一つの変化になんでこだわるんですかね
限りなく変化するんだったら
私はどういう変化のコマを大事にするんですか？他人を大事にする必要ないでしょうに
どんな現象であろうが
瞬間だけだからね もう二度と戻らない
戻らないんだから それは
やって変化の流れだけなんですね
だからそこを分かれば
別にブッダの輪廻の考え方は分かったことになってしまっちゃうんです
それは因果法則であって
無常の流れを見ることであって
変化の流れを見ることであって
実体はない世界であって
今も今すでにも実体ないんだから
私の何も生まれ変わりませんよ
今私でいた途端もうもう変わってるんだから
ただ流れがあるのみ だからまあそこをこのサンセットで目がある
見えるものがある それから煩悩が生まれたんだと
関わりが生まれたんだと
その三つだけずっと見ていると
関わりが生まれた 前にあった関わりが消えちゃったと
まあ音を聞いていたんだけど
さらに聞きたくなっちゃったんだけど
やっぱり目に何か他のもう入っちゃったんだから
そこに行っちゃうでしょうに
例えば窓を開けて音を聞いていると
いろいろと そこで珍しい鳥が飛んで行っちゃう
すぐ目に入るでしょ それであの関わりの流れがそちらに行っちゃうんですね
音ではなくて そうやってこの関わりもいろいろ変わっていくんだと
前の関わりは消えて 新しい関わりが生まれると
時々消えた関わりはもう二度と出てこないようにも消えちゃったりもする
そういう風な その関わりの流れを見ると
自分の体と他人の体と両方まとめて見てみればよろしいということ
そこでアッティダンマーティバーパナッサ
見るセットはね ずっと同じですから
もう1回繰り返します
もう忘れてるだろうと思いますからね
何ページ？ 13ページのこのあの DJT ページ474とかなんとか書いてるところにイティアッジャッタンワダンメスダンマヌパッシーヴィーラだ
自分の内なる法を見る
バヒッダーワダンメスダンマヌパッシーヴィーラです
外の方も見る 法っていうのをこの場合は六処と六境
その六十二ですね アッジャッタバヒッダーワダンメスダンマヌパッシーヴィーラ
それからまとめてそれしかないんだという感じで見る
それからサムデーワダンマヌパッシーワダンメスヴィーラという
生まれているものやと
誰々が消えているものやと見る
生まれて消えてるものやと見る
だから流れで見るって
私は使ってることはそういう言葉で
そこでアッティダンマーティバーパナッサティパッチュパッティタホーティ
そこであるのはこのダンマだよと
この流れですよと 私があるんじゃなくて
目があって それ目も変化する
見えるものがある それまた変化する
それでもうチャックインやな
眼識が生まれる それはまた変化するし
それで関わりが生まれる
それはまた変化するし
耳があって また同じ流れで
鼻があって同じ流れ そうやって
まあこういうややこしいからくりの流れだけですよ
それしか何もないという智慧が生まれてくる
そこで煩悩が消えるんだと
ヤーヴァデーヴァニャーナマッタヤパティッサティマッタヤ
そこで智慧 ほんのほんのほんのわずかな智慧が生まれるんです
アネッストーチャヴィーラティムタキンチローキウパティ
その人は何にも取柄することなく
生活できると これも法を見る一つの法なんですね
で こちらでこの法の観察を説明する場合は
このまた深い順番が決まってるんです
で まず瞑想に邪魔になるものか
瞑想上達するために見てほしいもの
五蓋で 五蓋は一番邪魔になっちゃうんで
五蓋見て見て見て勉強しなさいと
そこを見ると瞑想自体が上達してしまう
五蓋消えちゃったらそれでまた悟りの世界なんです
で 次に本当の存在って何なのかと
自分って何なのかという研究に入るんです
こちらで入ったのは五蘊と六処の話ですね
それは自分ということを勉強しなさいと
それで悟りで終わっちゃうんですよ
で それでもダメだったら
もう一回また瞑想上達するために必要な心の条件を見なさいと
次の方の観察に入るんです
だから瞑想を上達するために必要な心の状況を見る
それから自分を見る それで悟りに至る
うまく合格できなかったら
またもう一回 あなたにはそれ合わないかもしれません
だったらこれやってみなさいと
そちらも同じ順番なんです
瞑想を上達するために必要な条件を見る
それから自分って何なのかと見ると
なんです 瞑想を上達するために必要な条件を見る
それ悟りに至るはずなんです
次のセットなんですね
ポナチャパラン ビックウェー ビックー ダンメースー ダンマーヌパッシー ビエレディ サッタスー ボッジャンゲースー
この二十二に書いてるところ
カタンチャパナ ビックウェー ビックー ダンメースー ダンマーヌパッシー ビエレディ サッタスー ボッジャンゲースー
この場合はサッタスー ボッジャンゲースー
七つの うーんと ボッジャンカって何なんですかね
七つの覚支を見るんだと
何か問題ありますか とにかくこれからまた覚支の部
で 覚支の部でまたこの悟りに必要な瞑想に必要なもの
なぜ瞑想上達しないかと
あるいは瞑想上達するために何を気をつけた方が良いかというところで
この観察説明するんですね
七覚支のこと
イダ ビックウェー ビックー サンタンワアッジャッタン サティサンボッジャンガン アッティメー
アッジャッタン サティサンボッジャン ゴーティパジャナーティ アサンタンワアッジャンサティサンボッジャンガ
ナッティメ アジャッタン サティサンボッジャンガ オティ パジャーナティ
ヤター チャアヌッパンナッサ サティサンボッジャンガッサ ウッパードー ホーティ タンチャ パジャーナティ
ヤター チャアヌッパンナッサ サティサンボッジャンガッサ バワナーヤ パリプーリホーティ タンチャ パジャーナティ
一番目はサティ いわゆる確認する能力
物事を認識できる能力
だから物事は変化していく
変化しているものはすぐキャッチできるかと
やがてわかったって遅いんです
瞬時にキャッチして欲しいんですね
だからもう無常を見ればいいんだけど
世の中の人はいつでもサティは使ってますよ
でもあまりにも遅いんですね
だから無常というのは大変なことだとわからないんです
人が変わったとわかるためには十年ぐらいかかっちゃうんですね
その人のことを毎日見てる
全然わからないんですね
変わったんだと で たまたま一年
二年で見ると ああ変わったなと
あんた変わったなと言うでしょうに
あれも切実な言い方なんです
自分も変わっているのに
自分も変わっているのにキャッチしてないんです
自分が一年前の状況で同じくいると思ってるんですね
思っていて 「もうあんたそういうの変わりましたね」とか
って言ったりする まあそうやって人間が観察するこの変わりっていう
この変化っていうのはね
どうにもならない 何の知恵にもならない
あれは無知に基いてやってるんだから
まあ変わったっても変わらない何かあるんだとまた思ったりする
まああんた変わったって我々友情は変わりませんけど
変わってますよ 友情も
まあ二人も年取っちゃったんだけども
やっぱり友情だけはそのまんまです
嘘ばっかりで 学校で小さい時の友情かもしれない
それ変わるんですよ でもそれわかってない
まあですから それで悟りに取るわけじゃない
だからサティっていうのは
この物の変化はもうできるだけ早くキャッチすること
たまたまキャッチすることはどんなバカでもやってます
それじゃなくて できるだけ早くキャッチすると
それはサティサンボッジャンガなんですね
この変わっていくことをキャッチしてしまうんだと
だから悟りたいと思ってヴィパッサナーする人は悟れないでしょうし
かすかにでも知恵が上達しない
性格も変わらないし 変わるんだけど
悪いまんまで 悪い性格で
次にもまた同じぐらいか
もっとひどく悪いとかね
だからそういうことを何で言いますかというと
この あれはサティの瞑想じゃないんです
変化を見ようとしてるわけじゃないんだから
悟ろうと 凡夫の人が悟ろうと思うこと自体高慢でしょうに
煩悩でしょうに 見栄でしょうに
だからそうやって何か変わるの目的作って
そこを希望して もう何かやってるだけで
走ってるだけで だからそういう走り方っていうのは
リスは同じところでぐるぐる回ってることと同じなんですね
で 餌をぶら下がってる
そこを見ながらロバが歩くような感じで歩く歩く
いくら歩いたっても餌にはたどり着かなくなっちゃうし
ですからサティ 本物のヴィパッサナーのサティっていうのは
この変化をキャッチする能力なんですね
だからそこはどうしても真剣
真面目にやってもらわないと
この出世間の悟りの境地が出てこないんですね
ある一つの現象に入っちゃって
そこを味わっていたいんですね
ああ気持ちいいんだとか
ああ楽しいんだとか なんで瞑想して気持ちいいんですかとかね
もうそうダメですね そうすると
欲です だから気持ちいい時も気持ち悪いとか
まあ色々あるんですけど
やっぱりこの変化をキャッチする
ものすごい勢いで物事は変化していく
自分が変化していくんだと
[咳]まあそういう能力はサティと言いますね
だからこの変化をキャッチする能力はサティと言うんです
日常生活の中で どんな人間でもどんな動物でも持ってるサティは七覚支ではない
七覚支に入る念覚支ではないんです
動物にもサティがあるんですけど
あれはもう単なる勘の認識だけでね
餌と餌でないものを区別すると
それでもう煩悩の世界から脱出しません
だからパーリ専門用語ではそれはサティでないとまあはっきり言っちゃうんですね
私は機能としては同じだから似ているんだから
まあ別にどうったことないではないかと思いますけど
やっぱりアビダンマではやっぱりサティはサティで
先心所であの普通とは違いますと
サティは先心所ですよと
だったら犬猫の区別判断はサティにならなくなっちゃうんです
それは欲の働きになっちゃうんだと
そういうことから アビダンマ論ではそこら辺は論理的じゃないんです
この先心所のところで
やっぱり心所を抜けてるするんですよ
で 抜けちゃって そこはドーンとあの不善
じゃああの共一際心所のところで
まあ心所一つ抜けてるんですね
で あるいは次にまた六つありますからね
パケンナカット日本語の名前はわかりませんだけど
とにかく十三種類ありますね
どんな心にもだいたい生まれる
七つは必ず生まれる 残りの六つは適当に生まれたり生まれなかったりする
だからその中にある一つの働きでなきゃあかんですけど
そこに入れてないんですね
そこから抜いちゃって
先心所の二十五の中に入れてるんですね
十九のこの先心所の一共心所に入れているんです
だからそうやってわざとアビダンマは心理学的に論理的に見るとどうかなというところなんですけど
やっぱり仏教ではこれ仏教の世界だからね
単なる人に哲学を語ることじゃないんだからね
自分のためにやってる学問だから
悟りのためにやってる学問だから
そこら辺は抜けてサティが先心所に入れてるんです
サティが先心所に入れちゃったんだから
犬にも猫にもサティがあるということは言いにくく
言いにくくなっちゃうんです
でもその変化キャッチする機能であるならば
みんなにありますけど
虫にもありますけど 芋虫にも誰にでもありますからね
でもそこはまあやっぱり何か理解するためではなくて
ただ単に自分のために食えるか食えないか
敵かでそうでないかってぐらいの判断でしょ
動物の世界では 人間の世界ではもうちょっと
もうちょっとたくさんのものを判断する
でも全部我が身を守るためで終わってしまっちゃう
そういう時点で 動物とは同じ次元なんですね
で わざと音やら痛みやらなんとか何とかと確認しちゃうと
それは我が身を守るために
食えるためにやってるわけじゃないんですね
ご飯ですとわざと確認すると
食べますと運びますとか
そこの認識は食えるためじゃないってことをはっきりしてるでしょうに
食えるぐらい 食べるぐらいだったら
何のことなくパクパク食べればいいでしょうに
その時の区別判断で十分なんだ
これはちょっと美味しいとか
これはあまり美味しくないとかね
これはちょっと熱いとフーフーとやった方がいいやとかね
それぐらいの認識で十分でしょうに
でも熱いと待っているとかね
運ぶと噛む 味わう 飲み込むというところはもうまるっきり別ですよ
その場合は それでなくたっても食べられるのに
だからそうやってわざと確認を入れる時は
これはもう食うためにやってるわけじゃないんです
敵と味方 味方かと区別するためにやってるわけじゃないんですね
だからそこは善心所になって
真理を知るためにやっていることであって
実際に何があるかっていうことを知るためにやっていることだから
これは大変ありがたい専業になっちゃうんですね
心清らかにする道になっちゃうんです
だから例えば人が質問するとね
こうやってラベリングしながら仕事をできませんよとかね
それは無理でしょう だから自分がある別な時間だけでもうラベリングして
別とかそれはやれないとかね
いろいろ言うでしょうに
で その質問の中にある思考はそういう思考なんですね
自分たちがこの食うことしか頭の中にないんです
食えるかないか 敵か味方かという
味方かという この動物もやってる区別判断で
で わざわざとラベリングしちゃうと
これと道が違いますからね
上げます 下げます 下ろします
足を運んじゃうと普通の散歩と道が違うでしょうに
普通の散歩は雰囲気を楽しむために
体重を減らすためとかね
脂肪を燃やすために 健康のためにという
だから結局生きるためでしょうに
だから食うためっていうこと
そのカテゴリーに入っちゃうんですね
食うことは生きるためだからね
そこは瞑想にはならない
それでそういうことじゃなくて
ただ単に左足上げて運んで下ろすという機能ですよと
そうやって気向きをキャッチすることはサティであって
善であって 大変な徳行にもなります
徳を積むことになります
だからサティサンボジャンガ
念覚支ってなるのはそのようにサティを入れることなんです
そこで自分にこの能力
サンタンワアジャッタンサティサンボジャンガ
時々その能力あるんですよ
たとえヴィパッサナー瞑想していたっても
いつでも鋭くであるわけじゃないしね
時々ちゃんとサティが機能する
今サティがちゃんと回転しているんだと
アサンタンワアジャッタンサティサンボジャンガ
まるっきりサティがなくなっちゃった時は
もうサティが消えちゃったんだと
それサティが消えちゃったんだけど
また出てくると あ また出てきたんだと
またやりやすくなったと
そうやって確認すればいいんです
そうすると サティそのものにこの人がサティを実践するんじゃなくて
サティそのものにもサティ入れるんです
サティそのものにサティを入れるとサティが成長するんです
サティは別々に磨いてくるんです
今はなんかサティはダメだなと
今日はなんかサティがうまくいってるんだとかね
だから同じ分の間でもうまくいって
うまくいかないと 全くダメと
ものすごくうまく上手にいっちゃうと
もういろいろ流れがあるんですね
そこでサティそのものにもサティ入れると
サティというその覚支がどんどん成長していくんです
だから瞑想はうまくいく
成功する ですから まずサティにもサティ入れてくださいということで
サティにもサティ入れる方は
ある時はあると ない時はないと
ないサティが生まれると
ないサティが生まれてきたんだと
そうやってサティにサティ入れるとサティが完成するでしょうに
どんどん力強くなる あ
よく上手に上達していくんだとサティが
それにもそのつの立場で観察する
番目の覚支はサンタンワアジャッタンダンマヴィッチャヤサンボジャンガン
ダンマヴィッチャヤ 択法覚支と言うんですけど
これは区別能力なんです
[背景音楽]サティっていうのはキャッチする能力なの
変化をとにかくキャッチする
キャッチしただけで足らないんです
何なのかと区別する能力なんです
それはダンマヴィジャヤ
わからないかもしれませんだけど
例えばこれはヴェーデナーである
これはジュウである これは色であると
色とジュウは違いますよと知ってることなんです
これは音であると 音だと認識しちゃったんだと
これは香りだと 香りだと認識したんだと
香りという味覚と 味覚でしたっけ
嗅覚と音という聴覚というのはえらい違いますと
全く違う働きだと でも中に生まれる関わりは似ているんだとかね
嗅覚からも煩悩が生まれる
聴覚からも煩悩が生まれる
煩悩は同じだと似ているんだとか
そうやって区別判断できる能力はダンマヴィジャヤなんですね
択別覚 それもいつでも上手にということはないんです
時々もう時々ある 時々ダメ
ただ確認だけでラベリングだけでとかね
時々ラベリングだけじゃなくて
ちゃんと差がわかってくるとかね
それでそのその能力にもサティ入れておく
この区別判断できる能力にもサティ入れる
今ダンマヴィジャヤがあるんだと
今ダンマヴィジャヤがまるっきりないんだと
今またダンマヴィジャヤができてきたんだと
そうやって確認してしたら
ダンマヴィジャヤという覚支も成長していくんです
いわゆる区別能力もどんどん成長して増えていくんですね
3番目  14ページ サントァング アージャッタン ヴィリヤサンボッジャンガ アッティニ アージャッタン ヴィリヤサンボッジャンガンティ パジャーナ
この精進という覚支ですね
精進はどうしても必要なんです
皆様の前に美味しいご飯作ってあげてね
はい どうぞ食べてくださいって言ったら全然精進要りません
食いたくてたまらないんだから
ただ食べる じゃあみんなでワイワイと喋りましょうと思ったら
かなりうるさくても止まることなく喋るでしょうね
精進は要りません だから人間生まれたから死ぬまでやってることには何一つ精進要りません
仕事に頑張っていると誰も精進じゃないんです
もう 1 日 3時間しか寝てないで頑張ってるんだとかね
ただの欲だけでね 何のためにやってるんですかとね
まあ普通の人は食べるためにやってるんだから
その分意味があるんだけどね
体が真っ白くしてるあの女の人がススキその子でしたっけ？あの人がもう 1 日 3時間しか寝ないみたいでしょうに
朝から晩までいろんな仕事に手を出して頑張ってますよ
それからもう金があるというと
もう恐ろしいんでしょうに
日本ではないんだからね
自分でロールスロイス持ってる人っていうのは
で 何のためですかね あれほど頑張ったのは
普通の人だったら やっぱり夜も寝ないで頑張らなきゃ食えないんだと
子供たちには食べさせないんだと
家のローンが払えないんだと言うんだったら
じゃあ頑張ってくださいっていうこと言えるんだけどね
あのおばあさんに何言えばいいんですかね
ただのバカでしょ それで美術館作るんだとかね
迎賓館作るんだとかね
そういういろんなことをやって
何の意味もない 同じレベルの金持ちが集めて
また何か食って食べて
また別れて出て行く それだけのことで
だからそういうのは努力でも精進でもなんでもないんです
ただアホだからもう何かやってるだけ
ですから 普通の人々は仕事に頑張ってるんだ
勉強に励んでるんだというのは
仏教の善信の世界で 善の世界で徳の世界の精進ではありません
あれぐらいのことは誰でもやる
動物でもやる ペンギンさんでも 3ヶ月間でもじっと食べないで
あのね マイナス 20度ぐらいで卵は凍っちゃうでしょうね
あれ守ってますよ ほんのちょっとでも空気触れちゃったら卵終わりだから
命かけてもう体が痩せて痩せて痩せて痩せていくんですよ
体の中の脂肪を全部燃やしてるんだから
燃やしては卵を守る それでオスのペンギンがね
どこか遠く行って 魚いっぱい食べて食べて食べて食べて脂肪いっぱいもう溜まって体で
またもう 20キロでも 30キロでも歩いて歩いてくるんですね
ペンギン鳥ですよ 飛べないんだからね
歩いてきて 瞬時に卵交換させてもらって
また自分もこれからもう断食で卵を守ると
それでメスがまた餌食べるの
あれ人間より頑張ってるでしょうね
たったの卵 1個温めるために
で 悟りますかね あれで
だから頑張ってることはもう人間よりも頑張っている
だから努力してるんだから悟るって言ったら
それは違うんですね ですから
この人間の努力とこの七覚支の努力は違うということをわかってほしい
七覚支の努力のは努力しなきゃどうしてもできない
例えばいくらご飯あげてサティでご飯食べなさいと言ったら食べないでしょうね
ついもう 「あ これは美味しいわ」とかね 「
これもうちょっと温めた方がいいんですよ」とかね
結局欲の方にもう行ってるんでしょ
それだったら努力は要りません
だからわざとね 取ります
運びます 入れます 噛みます
噛みます 飲み込みますということは
もうあまり面白くはないんだからね
精進なしにはできません
歩く時でも もうバカみたいに上見たり
右見たり 下見たりとか歩くのは簡単でしょうね
あ ワンちゃんだとかね
あ 女の人だ 男の人だとかね
とかを見ながら ホームレスの人がいるんだとかね
そんなことにあること誰にでもできますよ
左足上げます 運んでいます
下ろします これ難しいんです
それには特別に働かないと
特別に努力しないと そのサティ入れたがる気持ち自体が本当の精進なんです
それは精神性でもあって
徳にもなるし 善にもなるし
心は清らかにもなるし
自分が上達もする 仕事を頑張ってるんだからって精神的に上達するっていうことはありえない
スポーツに頑張ってるんだからといって精神的に上達しましたと
それでもって死んだところで天国に生まれたんだ
それはありえない そう思う人々もいるんです
だから国民のヒーローではないかと
国のために金メダルは 4個取ったんだと言って死んじゃったところで
何か慰霊碑というんですか
何かそうやって慰霊碑みたいなものも建てて
みんな集めて 何かもうやっちゃったんだからといって
今天国にいるあなたに今とか
我々はもう悲しい時をあなたはよく励ましてくれたとか
嘘ばっかり言って もうそこ前にあるのは石だけなんですけど
そういう儀式をやっちゃうでしょうね
何の意味もないんだけど
それで天国には行けません
その人はただ金メダル取りたいという欲で頑張っただけで
それよりはペンギンの方がありがたい
偉い タコの方がもっと偉いんです
タコのお母さんが だから客観的に見てないだけ
日本に初めての世界チャンピオンのベルトを持ってきたのはこの人ですよと
偉くも何ともないんです
タコ相手には負けますからね
タコには 誰でも ですから
そういう努力で素晴らしいと思う宗教を間違ってるんですね
そこでお釈迦様のところにあるアクロバティックの人が来て
アクロバティックというのは中国にありますね
人間にできないほどのことをやってるでしょう
体がねじ曲げたり ものすごいいろんなことをやったりと
この 特に中国は世界一だから
その点ではね 誰にも真似できないんだから
だってもう八歳 六歳 それぐらいの小さな時で
才能ある子供たち捕まってもう毎日毎日訓練させちゃったりして
だから能力はもうもう文句なし世界一
他の誰にも真似できないすごいことをやる
体の体操とかね それ誰でももう驚いちゃって
口を開けてお金払って見るしかもう方法ないんです
じゃあ私も真似してみよう
どれもできませんだから
誰にでも で そうやってこのアクロバティックの人がいくつかの人々
たまたま来たんだけどね
私はこういう命かけて高い棒の上に乗って逆立ちしたり
いろんなもうアクロバティックやったりして頑張ってるんだと
だから命かけて頑張ってるんだと
ほんのちょっとでも間違ったらもう落ちて死んじゃいますからね
それ見てみんな大変喜ぶんだと
私はみんなのために みんなを喜ばすためにそういうことをやってるんだと
だから我々は死んだら
もうそういうアクロバティックの
そういう命かけて頑張ってる人々のためにある天国があるんだから
そこに行くんだと お釈迦様はそれをどう思いますか？と
それ本当ですよと言ったら
まあまあそんな話しちゃいましょう
でお釈迦様言うんですね
いいわ そんな話はと 言ったら
いいえ そうじゃなくて
そういう我々の伝統では名前がありまして
なんとかの まあ一応アクロバティック天と言いましょうか
仮に もうアクロバティック天に生まれ変わるんではないかという話がありますから
その話にお釈迦様はどう考えてますかと聞いたら
まあ言ったんだからそんな話よしましょうよと
他のことを話しましょうと
いいえ 私はこれ知りたいんだと
だって私は命かけて人々のためにこれぐらいのことやってるんだから
これ何か意味があるか知りたいんだと
あんた三回目に聞くんですかと
そうですと 地獄に落ちますよと
天に行くどころか そういうアクロバティックの連中がいる地獄があるんだ
私は知ってますと みんなそちらに落ちてるんだと
一人の彼人 それは本当のことなんです
じゃあペンギンよりは偉いんですかね？あれも
まあいくらかもしかすると似てるかもしれませんが
あれぐらいのアクロバティックだったら
だったら全てのペンギンが天国に行くでしょう
全てのタコは全ての方じゃなくて
タコの卵を産んだタコたちがみんな天国に行くでしょう
だからそれぐらいのことは誰でもやってます
それぐらいの努力っていうのは
人間がやってる努力とは何のこともないんです
何のこともないんです
戦争に行ってひと頃給料もらってるんだから
だから戦争をやめないでしょうに
いくら自分やってること間違ってるってことは絶対やめません
金がなくなっちゃいますから
入るお金があれでヒーローとかね
っていうのはよくないんですよ
戦争を作る国民も悪いし
だから国民にとっては自分のためにって
もうもう戦ってきた人はね
ヒーローで見なきゃね
それはすごい失礼でしょうし
だからといってそんなことはもうどうってことはないんですね
だから精進っていうのは
そうやって このもう食べるために
卵を守るために命かけることじゃないんです
音楽のために一生かかっちゃったんだというね
なんのことはない 地獄に落ちるだけ
そんなことをやって だからそういう努力っていうのは誰にでもできる
私たちでも何か頑張ってみたら
楽器なんか弾ける能力あるなと思ったらやるでしょうに
ちょっとチャレンジしてみたら
あら うまく音が出るんじゃないかと
じゃあそれで次にまたやってみて
またやってみて そこでもし才能が出てきちゃったら
まあ元気で じゃあ次に私の発表会ですよと行って
はがきでもね はがき作ってみんなに配ったりして
来てちょうだい 来てちょうだいとやりますから
もうそれは別にそんなに褒めるぐらいのことじゃないんです
それよりも左足上げます
囲います 下ろしますと確認しながら歩くことは難しいんです
それには努力が必要なんです
あれは生きるためでもないんです
食べるためでもないんです
収入を得るためでもないんです
だからみんなやりにくくて
いろいろ何かつまらなくなったりして
そこで精進してやらなくちゃいけない
それで真理を体験できますからね
煩悩なくなりますから
だからそれだけ専心 専業で専行位なんです
だから精進といっても全て精進ではないんです
こちらで言っているのは
カクシになる精進なんです
だから我々日常生活でやっている精進はそんな威張るもんじゃないんで
当たり前のことで 私は大変だ
忙しいんだ 家を守らなくちゃいけないんだとかね
お母さんの面倒見なくちゃ
旦那の面倒見に行けないんだと思っちゃったらね
もうそれももうバカもいいところで
もうどう頑張っていてもタコよりはイカだからね
だからもう一般的にそういうのはやればよろしいしね
文句言うところでもない
こちらへんは頑張って
サティを入れちゃえば
それは本物の精進なんです
だからその精進もあったりなかったりする
そこで瞑想過程でその精進が出てきたら
もう今やる気が出ているんだと
今なんか頑張りたくないなとかね
ちょっと休みたくなったなとか
そこで精進が消えたと
で また精進が生まれたんだと
そうやって精進にもサティ入れてみる
そうすると精進自体もどんどんどんどん強化になって完成してしまっちゃうんです
それ三番目精進 ヴィリヤサンボッジャ
パーリ語でヴィリヤサンボッジャングアですね
次に出てくるのはピーティサンボッジャンガ
三端はアッジャッターン
ピーティサンボッジャンガ
これアッジャッターと書いてアッジャッタンですけど
三端目アッジャッタン
ピーティサンボッジャンガ
アッティミアッジャッタン
ゴーディパジャーナ ピーティということ
喜なんで喜びなんですね
それでまた同じ説法を繰り返さなくちゃいけないんですよ
世の中でみんな喜んでるでしょうね
あれ サティサンボッジャンガじゃない
あれサンボッジャンガじゃないんです
あれは喜隠支じゃないんです
犬も喜んでいるんだから
どうってことはないんです
だからそんなことはもう何のこともなく
喜ぶんだったらどんなことでもやると
楽しいんだったら何でもやるということぐらいのことは
もう犬猫さえもやっている
犬を喜ばせればいろんな芸を教えられるでしょうに
可愛がってくれるんだったら何でもやってあげるんだって犬も決まってるんだから
可愛い子 いい子だいい子だと
愛情いっぱい猫を褒めてあげちゃうと
まあボールを持ってくるわ
フリスビーを捕まるわ
もう後ろ足で立ってくれるわ
もうはい ワンワンと言ってくださいと言いなさいと言ったらワンワンと鳴いてくれるわ
まあ死にふりを死んだふりをしてくれる
何でもやってくれます
だからそちらにも喜びがあるんだから
で それやっちゃったら餌ももらっちゃうし
また可愛がってももらっちゃうし
それぐらいのことだから
世の中でみんな喜びを目がけて頑張ってるんだけど
それはもう成長の道ではありません
ただ誰でもやってることです
だから何かやり続けると喜びがあるとみんなやり続く
例えば 人の噂なんかは 3時間でも喋れるでしょうに
立ったまんまでも 無駄話だったら何時間でも喜びなんですね
くだらん話を喋るの そうすると立ったまんまでも喋れる
大事なことを喋るようになっちゃったら
すぐメモを書いたり そうですね
ええとですねとか言いながらかなり踏ん張らないと喋れないんですね
まあですから 喜びの世界っていうのは誰でもやってるんだから
その喜びはもう単なる地獄に行く道であって
全然成長ありません 私はもう全然悲しくない
人生は楽しい一方ですよと
だから死んじゃったら天国行くんだと
それ大違い アホだから地獄に落ちるんです
これほど世の中で悲しくなるなんじゃいかないこといっぱいあるのに
この人それに無関心で楽しがってるんだったら
私はいろいろご飯食べてるけど
一向に楽しくないんです
なぜかとすぐ頭に浮かぶね
食べることなくて あの死にかけてる子供たちやらね
いろんな国々で あのインドネシアであっちこっちでね
もう家ごとに全部燃やしちゃってね
そこでみんな行くところがなくて悲しんでいるとかね
こんなだから おいしいご飯だ
これすごい高い食べ物
そんな喜びっていうのは何の意味もないんです
ですから まあ世の中ではみんな普通にそうやって
まあ我々日本で生まれてよかったとかね
昨日テレビでこの小さな小型車作ってる何とかのニュース番組みたいなのがあって
このどこかで この富山県でしたっけ
この注文受けて 一般の人々の注文に応じて小さな車を作ってるみたいで
そこで日本の政府もそれを認めて登録もできて
すごい安い もう大体もう自分で注文してデザインしてもらって
自分好きな色で またガソリン代もすごい安いし
電気の車もあったりするし
まあ作ってもらっちゃえばね
だから 1つしかないとかね
安くてね で そこの認可を得たことで
もうその まあただ遊びでやった仕事なんですけど
一応もうかなり売れてるんだと
かなり売れてるんだと
だからもう普通の軽自動車よりも半分 4 分 1 ぐらいのエネルギーで動いていたりして
結構可愛くてかっこいいんですよ
自分がドアが上から開けて中に入ったければ
そういう風にデザインしてくれる
もう頭の方がもっと違う形で欲しいなと思ったら
はい わかりました そういう風にデザインしてくれると
ほとんど手作り で まあいいことなんですけど
そこで日本の政府は認可したことで
その人がやっぱり私たちはもうクスクスと
もう遊びみたいな感じで始めたんだけど
認可してくれたことはありがたいことで
日本に生まれてよかったんだと
アホやと お前 日本に生まれて悪かったと思いなさいと一人勝手に思っちゃったんですね
だから一人 の動力認可することはあれほどケチる
ケチるというんですかね
あれほど戸惑っても どうしようか
どうせ認可下らなかったでしょうね
それぐらい人に邪魔している
このくらい人に邪魔している
この国の法律に腹が立つべきでしょうね
日本人がいろんな技術を持ってるんだから
技術を持ってることは当たり前で
技術を持ってるやつらは何でもいいんだから
いろんなことをアイデア
商品出しなさいと政府は容認しますよと言った方がいいのに
そうしてないんです ただ
大型の会社だけ守るために
厳密に遠い昔決めた決まりで凝り固まってるんだから
本当は日本で生まれてよかったと思う感想が悪いんです
日本で生まれたんだから
自分の能力は未だに世間に貢献することはできなかったと
やっと遅くなってでも評価したことはありがたいと思った方が良かったのに
やっぱりバカなんですね
それでも まあ一応か まあそういう単純な言葉だから
みんなね まあ言ってるんですけど
それだったらアメリカに生まれてもっとよかったよ
何でもできますからね
能力さえあれば 政府はもう邪魔しませんから
こちらは政府は人の請求はとことん邪魔をする
大きな会社しか守ってあげない
中小企業なんかは死んでしまえと
どうでもいいという感じで
ということだからね 悪いんですよ
結局 まあだからそういう見方もスクロールすればできますけど
とにかくこの喜びという
で そうやっていろんなことで人は喜ぶ
新しいものをできた 作れた
でもそういうことでも喜ぶ
そこでお客さんが注文してくれると
その人すごく楽しいんですよ
自分がもうコスクスと始めた仕事だから
注文が入っちゃったんだと
一人の女の子が来て 私はこういう風な車が欲しいのだったら
じゃあこんな形でいいんですか？いい
もうちょっとこういう方向からちょっと低く
あ そう じゃあここらへんこれぐらい低くしましょうと
そうやって話し合って
じゃあ OK と それ楽しいんですよ
作る人にとっても 手作りで車を作る人にとっても
だから一生懸命苦労して
バカなこと言わないで
わがまま言わないで 何の人々の人のために
これぐらい設計図書いてリサイズしなくちゃいけない
これ 1個作ったら この全部青写真捨てなくちゃいけないでしょうに
次の人には違うものだから
ああいう文句言わないでと喜んでやってるんです
でもあれで天国には行かないんです
悟りもしません ああいうのは普通の喜び
世の中にある普通の喜び
だからこちらでやる喜びっていうのは違う喜びなんですね
この頑張って自分が精進すると喜びが生まれるんです
あの人々も世俗次元で精進すると喜びが生まれるんです
同じくこういう精神次元でもサティを実践しようではないかと
ややこしいんだけど 食べる時でもサティを実践してみようではないかと
めんどくさいんだけど
やっぱり布団を敷く時にも取ります
行きますとかやりましょうとというふうなことをやっちゃうと
やっぱり頑張ってるでしょ
それ精進です そうすると喜びが生まれてくる
そうやってこのヴィパッサナー実践において生まれてくる喜び
で そこは素晴らしい喜びで
善であって 心は上達する
心にはどうしたって喜びっていうものは必要なんですね
それはしょうがないので
脳細胞っていうのは刺激で動いてるもんだから
やっぱり喜びが必要なんです
喜びになってはもう機能がもうどんどん衰えてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから この機能を開店してもらうために
すごく喜びが生まれてほしい
精進次第に喜びが生まれる
で 喜びがあると 今は喜びがあるんだと
やりやすいんだと 今喜びがないんだと
という風に ある時はある
ない時はないと また生まれたらまた生まれたんだと
消えちゃったら消えたぞとかね
で あるいはまたそうやって喜びにもサティを入れると
あの喜隠支がまた完成していくんです
次の隠支は何なのかと
今日は  うんうん 今日はパッサッビ
パッサッビっていうのはこの軽くなるということで
本当に体も軽々と動くようになるんですよ
あれはこの集中力のことで
この例えばサティでもって
この感じながら手を動かしたり
足を動かしたりすると
いとも簡単に動くようになるんです
体っていうのは空気のように動くようになるんですね
この中国の人々がね まあまあ欲の塊なんですけど
この気功とかね 気とか何とかしながらやっているのは
単なる体の動きに集中する
それもスローモーションで
そうでなきゃ出てこないんだから
心が混乱するんだから
だからスローモーションでこうやっていろんないろんなことをやったり
それに変な概念いっぱいサンデンとか何とかとかね
いっぱい概念作っちゃうとまたかっこつけちゃうでしょ
それでこうやったら何々か
こうやったら何とかとか
これで何々の何かの形
こうやったら何かの形とかやってますね
それ その人の体に本当に気というエネルギーが生まれてくるんですね
その気というエネルギーっていうのは
単なる物質のエネルギーで
あの集中力によって生まれるんです
だから 手をこうやってゆっくり動かすと
本当に手の動きを指先まで感じてやると
何か違うエネルギーで手を動かしているんだということがわかるんですね
普通の手は重いんですよ
こうやって感じながら動かしちゃうと
この動かすエネルギーがすぐ感じちゃうんです
できる人にはもう 1  2 秒でできるんですよ
これ何年もやる必要ないんです
もう私にも 1 分以内で作れますけど
膨大なこのエネルギーっていうのは
だからこの 何のことない
ただの物質のエネルギーなんですけどね
その物質のエネルギーは心が作るんですよ
そこをできちゃうと これ動きのエネルギーでしょ
体がすごく軽いんです
歩くのもなんか雲の上に歩くように
空気の上に歩くようにもうすごく気持ちよくなるんですね
そうすると心はどうしても集中しているし
集中力 心もややこしいところ
ギザギザなところ もう混乱したり葛藤したり
これ何もないんです スムーズにサティも入っちゃうんですね
やりたくない でもやらなきゃこのボスに怒られるとかね
そういうもうもう何もなくて
スムーズに心も動いちゃうんです
そこ平安ということなんですね
そこはもう気功と同じく努力すれば生まれてくるものなんです
喜びがあったら簡単に出てくるんですね
その平安というのは すごく軽くなったりするんです
体が だからそれ一生あるんだと思ったら
それは大違いで 無常だからね
時にあったり また消えたり
もうちょっと軽くなったんだけど
次のはものすごい10倍体が重く硬くなったとかね
それはよくありますよ
確実にあると言っちゃったら
これ無常に反しますからね
ですから たとえどんな気功師であろうとも
気持ち落ち込んじゃったらできなくなっちゃいますよ
ですから まあそういうことで
まあまあ訓練すると訓練すると完成する
完成すると そんな滅多なことで落ち込む
消えることではなくなっちゃう
確定したわけじゃなくて
いつでも作られるというぐらいのことですから
平安がある時はあるんだと
消えちゃったら消えちゃったんだと
ない時はないんだと 生まれたら生まれたんだと
で 平安にもサティ入れちゃうと
平安という働き自体ももう完成します
平安ということも あのまあ
これ瞑想にはすごくいいんですよ
例えば じゃあ平安というのは中国の気功の世界にあるんだから
彼らには悟りはないんだ
違います あれは世間の世界です
あれでは天国にも行けません
確かに同じ働きは作っても
あれでもどうやって儲かるかと
それしか考えてないんだから
どうやって人の膝のルーマチを治してあげるかとかね
それしか考えてないんです
だからそれは普通の仕事の世界です
宗教の世界じゃないんです
その人々 たまたまちょっとちょっと興味ありますよ
宗教のことにも でもやっぱりすごい汚れ好きなんですね
相手にしたくならないんですね
一回私もそういうことをどこかで講演に行きましたけどね
その先生は中国人でも立派な人ですけどね
まず最初に言うんで 我々はこういうこういう方法で
なんとかの集中力の方法で
このみんなにこの健康的で長生きできるようにということでやってるんですよと
それはもう正直に言っちゃったら
こちらの話とは違うでしょう
だから仏教の経安の世界は言えなくなっちゃうんですね
そこは正直だから 別にもうからくりあるわけじゃなくて
その人は来てる人々もそうやってご利益
現世利益のために来てるんですね
美しくなるために 長生きするために
病気治すためにというぐらいのことで
中国の気功なしに気功なしではなくて
気功入り瞑想みたいなことをやりましょうと
そこでまあヴィパッサナーって何なのかと聞いてるだけで
聞かない方が良かったんだけど
それでも  それでもまあほんのちょっとこの論理をね
どういう働きですかと
なぜ私は逆になぜ人が病気になるかと
それ説明したんですね
それはもうあんた方は欲ばっかしでね
希望ばっかしでね 怒りばっかしで
だから病気になるんだと
だから心を落ち着いちゃったら元気になりますよと
方法は何でもいいんだけど
心を落ち着いてもらってくださいと
安定した心を作れと そうするとすごく健康で病気なしに長生きできますよということを言った話を終わりましたけどね
一人の女の人だけもうとことん反論しちゃったんだけど
それその人の妄想概念でもうこちらのテキストを読んでいるんです
その人だけ 読んでいて色々反論するんですね
まあ一応この経安というものはそういうことで
世の中にもあります 世の中にいたってはだいたい中国だけですけど
中国の文化の中では その経安という働きを働かせて
人が病気 病気 人の病気を治すとか
そういう仕事はやってます
それはあくまでも世俗次元でやっていることであって
出世間次元のものでないんです
ヨーロッパではそういう話はあまりない
全くないぐらいですね
でもこのちゃんと頑張っちゃうと
心サティ入れながら歩いたり座ったり
いろんな行動したりすると
いとも簡単にその心の軽さっていうのは体の軽さっていうのはもう生まれてきます
そうするとさらにやりやすい
だからといってそれは心次第だから生まれたり消えたりする
それもちゃんと完成してほしいんです
なくなってほしいんじゃなくて
例えば私は中国人に悪口言ったんだから
それ悪いって意味じゃないんです
それは清らかな方法で完成してほしい
例えば喜ぶのは悪いとは言ってないんです
誰でも喜んでもよくやってるんではないかと
だからそこでは地獄に落ちちゃいますから
清らかな方向で喜びを完成してくださいと
頑張ることはみんな頑張っちゃいますけど
もうあんまり大した頑張ることじゃないんですね
ただ地獄に落ちるだけのことですから
この清らかな方向で努力してくださいとっていう話だけなんです
次は何なの？何でしたか？サマーディ
そこで体も心も落ち着いたところで
このとく 軽く動くようになったところでサマーディということが生まれてくる
これ集中力なんですけど
普通世の中の集中力とは違う
世の中でも我々は何かに集中しちゃったら我忘れてもうそれしか見えなくなっちゃう時はあります
我が身忘れて何かやるという
それもサマーディもどきなんですけど
もう善なるサマーディでも何でもないんです
こちらで私という我を忘れて
それだけ集中できるということも
全て忘れてしまいます
自分がいるということも忘れて
ただ機能だけ見ていられるというサマーディが出てくる
これはもうこちらではもう善の方で
サマーディで終わりますかね
あ ウペッカー で 最後に必要なのはウペッカー
落ち着き 驚いてはあげません
ああ 経安が生まれた これこそ奇巧だ
まあこれでよかったとかね
まあ中国の方法でも これ年
年も苦行修行しなきゃいられないのに
週間でこれ入っちゃったんだから
それはもうもうダメですね
そういう人々が舞い上がったり喜んだりすると
まあ何でも変化していくもんだからね
もう頑張ったんだからそうなったと
だから何ですかと 当たり前のことじゃないかと
例えば喜びが生まれたんだからと
これはもう一生懸命苦しんで瞑想したんだからね
喜び生まれたわけであって
まあどうったことないんだというふうな
この落ち着き どんなものも消えていくんだと
だからこの心のすごく落ち着きが必要なの
そのつがそいちゃったらヴィパッサナー瞑想達成するんです
だからなんで瞑想うまくいかないかというと
このつは成長してないんですね
だからサティにもサティ入れてない
そうやってもうこれを法能観察なんです
法能観察って この第ニセットでお釈迦様はまず瞑想上達することを教える
いわゆる瞑想をなぜうまくいかないか
邪魔になって なぜなぜ瞑想はうまくいかないかというと
この七覚支がないんだからと
だったら七覚支にサティ入れてみなさい
七覚支にも 七覚支にもサティ入れちゃうと
七覚支はどんどんどんどん成長していくと
成長してくると抜群に瞑想うまくいく
それで次に私は何者かと観察に行きなさいと
次のセットはまた同じく五蘊の代わりに違うやり方で
私は何者かという観察に行きます
まあ一応そこら辺で  [終始清咳]